تؤدي الحرب العالمية الأولى إلى الحرب العالمية الثانية ، حيث
يأتي اليوم التالي ليلاً
بنهاية الحرب العالمية ، حيث
يتطلع الجميع للاستفادة من
[موسيقى]
نسميها الحرب العالمية الأولى ، الحرب العالمية الثانية ،
لكنها في الحقيقة مرحلتان مختلفتان من
نزاع عالمي واحد
يحدث للتو.  وضع الناس
أذرعهم لمدة 20 عامًا ثم
عادوا إلى القتال مرة أخرى.
وأنا لا أمزح
، يقول إنني علف مدفع لعام 1940.
كانوا يعرفون أن
أي شخص لديه نصف دماغ كان يعلم أن
معاهدة فرساي كانت أساسًا
البندقية الأولى للحرب العالمية الثانية
[موسيقى]
العالم الأول  تعافى من أضرار
الحرب العالمية الثانية بسرعة ملحوظة
بحلول الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي وتوطد
النمو الاقتصادي المحلي المدفوع بالتكنولوجيا
وتوطدت عملية
النمو الاقتصادي الحديث وارتفاع
مستويات المعيشة في العمل الأول  ld
قوي جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
أنت